Sona I think you need to apologize
what did I do what this time I know
that's the thing is I I was saying to
Gorly he's he said to me uh should we do
some kind of new segment and I said
let's just do a segment called Sona
apologizes and
um it's just because I know you've done
something bad I I don't know what it is
you know I've dealt wait I know that
you've screwed something come clean Sona
tell us first of all what it is you did
wrong and then please apologize what are
you doing I don't know what are you
doing well okay that's a safe assumption
that you've done something you probably
made a restaurant reservation and said
it was for Conan O'Brien and then you
and Tack went but I wouldn't apologize
The Cheesecake Factory does not require
you call ahead I know I've waited for
over an hour for the Cheesecake Factory
but I don't know I don't think I've done
any I mean the thing is though because I
don't do as much as I used to do right
so the chances of me screwing something
up have fallen a lot because now
whenever you ask me to do something I
really want to like you know you want to
please me no I want I want to keep
getting no I want to keep getting paid
yes I see so like I want to just keep
doing is there anything in the past you
want to dig deep maybe find something
from the past apologize
yeah about something I should apologize
to you for don't you think in general
you just I'm saying blanket Gorly like
in general you should just apologize do
you want to apologize to me well listen
that could be another segment and I
don't think we'll have time for it you
said a family emergency is if my dad's
mustache went on strike you said this
like a week ago what are you talking
about yeah you said that you said that
doesn't even a joke you that's a
fragment you said you said a family
emergency for Sona is if her dad's
mustache went on strike that's honey
okay did you said it I just wanted you
to say it right how many times have you
pet my head and you've you've like
smelled your hand and you've got garlic
yeah and you've also said you've also
said you know I need an industrial press
to straighten my hair your hair is out
of control yeah you know what then we
had to get you know when we started
doing the podcast we didn't think about
this we just used regular uh headsets
you know by by sure they're the best
headsets in the business if you ask me
I'm glad they have their name on the
side but we forgot about sona's hair
your hair is so powerful that uh we had
to get we had to go to the US Army Corps
of Engineers and have them engineer out
of steel they just used an old bear trap
they used to Bear Trap yeah it's
basically yes exactly you told me you
said that my dad's uh built my brother
out of wood and that he wanted him to be
a real boy God you have she has so many
memories of my good bits yes did I say
that your father who looks a little like
Geppetto had built your older brother uh
possibly out of wood and because he
dreamed of having a real boy yes I did
make that offhanded quip once once you
probably said it to a member of the
press
or like or like an Obama or someone
important that like I I want to think
I'm interested like cool and interesting
I did at Great length explained to
President Barack Obama that uh my
assistant sona's brother was carved out
of wood by his father well so Sona do
you want to apologize
what I don't think first of all I think
these are all Class A Bits good material
they solid Landing I mean the fact that
I'm able to be this creative around you
uh I think should be a source of wonder
in an increasingly competitive job
market it's important to make sure your
brand stands out from the crowd that is
important Sona yeah that's right vegan
cupcakes from your kitchen or marketing
your wedding photography business I'm
just making these up yeah I can tell
Squarespace helps you create a man
modern platform through engaging and
aesthetically pleasing online presence
that's important if things look nice
people will buy with member areas you
can unlock a new Revenue stream for your
business and free up time in your
schedule by selling access to gated
content like videos online courses or
newsletters newsletters yeah send out in
any inbox with email from Squarespace
email campaigns collect email
subscribers and convert them into loyal
customers social just play posts from
your social profiles on your website
analytics you want to hear more I'll
give you some use insights to grow your
business learn where your site visits
and sales are coming from and analyze
which channels are most effective good
heavens and alert above head to
squarespace.com in for a free trial when
you're ready to launch use offer code
Conan to save 10 off your first purchase
of a website or domain how many stores
have we walked into where you're like
watch out for her she's Steals and she's
got Sticky Fingers no I I said you steal
babies
that's right okay oh but you've also
said I just steal to like stores we just
walk into well no one specifically was
an eyeglass store we went into yeah I
said watch out for her she says she's
got Sticky Fingers and you know what and
you know what they followed you around
after that I was gonna say they didn't
know you were joking so they actually I
wasn't joking
need to apologize to me I think uh I
think first of all that's a dangerous
precedent for me to admit to any crime
um and uh to apologize I think that's a
road we shouldn't go down but I'm gonna
take your admission that you steal and
steal often as an apology and that no
that doesn't mean oh okay no he just
went
no is that a special know that you
reserve for special times me admitting
something doesn't mean I'm apologizing
for it I'm just admitting that it
happened I think that you if you're not
going to apologize to me I'm not going
to apologize to you why should I do it
if you're not gonna do it well
if you paid me recently all right I'm
sorry this I'm this is just how it works
I'm the guy who's writing the check
somebody needs to apologize to someone
so I'll do it no thank you how many
times have you tried to smack my hair
bun have you seen me do that no she gets
her hair in a bun oh yes and I take a
whack at it and if I do it just right
the little elastic goes
and the hair goes and it fills the whole
room you're in it's great it's so much
fun
so now I'm gonna end this right now you
have nothing to apologize for you're a
wonderful person you're a good friend
we've been through a lot together my
lawyer made me uh remember and I think
because you're telling me not to
apologize now I'm gonna say I'm sorry oh
really wow mission accomplished mission
accomplished and Gurley I think you owe
us both an apology you got it ready to
come in here with your Mr Rogers sweater
okay uh no I'm sorry but uh you know
what I mean yeah these are the people
that you meet in the neighborhood in the
neighborhood that's Sesame Street yeah
that's not the song what these are the
people in your neighborhood
no you're talking about a wonderful day
in the next beautiful day in the
neighborhood a beautiful day for our
neighborhood which one is Cookie Monster
on Sesame Street
apologize I'm realizing now I really
don't like Mr Rogers Neighborhood oh my
God Sesame Street wait are you for real
you know the neighborhood of
Make-Believe is in is in Mr Rogers I'm
sorry I'm re-watching all this stuff
yeah
every day yeah wait what are we talking
about now I got lost well we just watch
a lot of children's programming right
because you have kids I just sit there
and watch it as just a fan oh I see yeah
I'm like Mr Rogers is on I gotta you
know
I gotta get my cereal out and watch
those are good times look I got off the
rails there a little bit we'll clean it
up where Did We End we got Sona to
apologize we got someone to apologize
and Corley has apologized uh and uh I
never did actually I said I would yeah
anyway
do you wanna you just you're not gonna
apologize for anything what have I done
except take care of you and your
extended family
um I am the son and you are a plant that
grows uh because of my raise my
beneficent golden Rays I'd like you to
apologize for your weird metaphors
no sometimes the sun will sunburn you
yeah and I think that the sun owes that
person an apology
I am the son and I apologize for that
sunburn that's funny the sun is just
I provide all life on Earth yeah I know
what about that sunburn that guy got in
Bermuda
he's very pale and he didn't son
oh all right what about Icarus that was
his fault that was icarus's fault all
right son I apologize to Charles
Millman of Canoga Falls Ohio
for burning his shoulders it made his
stay unpleasant and he had to buy aloe
gel
now maybe you'd like to thank me for all
the crops we're good son bye
son is just so all right we did it okay
good